[Aplausos]
[Música]
buenas tardes a todos
me gustaría empezar por reforzar el tema
que vamos a platicar en el día de hoy
esta es la evolución del marketing que
creo firmemente que tiene que ver con la
evolución de la humanidad hasta llegar a
su status quo que es el status quo
simplemente es el hoy en la hora lo que
vive actualmente la industria del
marketing y qué es lo que vive
actualmente la industria
bueno esto influye significativamente en
todos nuestros días de manera formal o
informal de manera consciente o
inconsciente desde que nos levantamos y
elegimos la ropa que nos vamos a poner a
los lugares que salimos con colegas o
amigos desde las apps que tienes en tu
celular y los productos que consumes día
con día
para esto les quiero contar una historia
de cómo me relacioné yo con esta
industria que ha sido mi casa por más de
10 años
y esto parte dos años antes de llegar a
la ciudad de monterrey a estudiar la
licenciatura de mercadotecnia ya había
trabajado para un videoclub es un
videoclub para los que no están
familiarizados
bueno era una de estas tiendas con un
peculiar aroma a palomitas y dulces
donde siempre estaban los mejores
estrenos tanto en películas como
videojuegos y a mí me tocaba conocer un
montón de niñas bonitas que querían que
les recomendar una película
usar el trabajo soñado para cualquier
adolescente en esa edad pero bueno la
historia no iba por ahí la historia pasa
cuando regreso a monterrey llegó a
monterrey estudia la licenciatura de
mercadotecnia y a los dos años me enteró
que había rumores de una posible
bancarrota o quiebra de esta empresa
no me hacía sentido era una
transnacional que tenía apenas en el
2004 más de 9000 establecimientos en
todo el mundo y empleaba a más de 84 mil
empleados que podía haber pasado mal tan
rápido que yo no podía leer las pistas
que estaban pasando ahí
y fue cuando lo relacione con un
concepto que escuché de steve jobs
conectados
esto significa conectar los puntos de tu
vida
que van dándole un mayor propósito en
donde quieres impactar
bueno comentaba steve jobs al respecto
en la etapa en la universidad como la
mayoría están aquí en este momento era
muy difícil era muy difícil ver para qué
me van a servir las cosas que estaba
haciendo ahorita en el futuro
sin embargo cuando volteas diez años
atrás cinco años atrás todo hace sentido
de una manera mucho más sencilla es para
esto que quiero hacer un ejercicio aquí
con ustedes en el cual vamos a repasar
rápidamente la evolución del marketing
que firmemente creo como lo dije orita
que está relacionada con la evolución de
la humanidad y ahorita van a ver porque
empiezo en 1450 con la invención de la
imprenta en masa a manos de guttenberg
básicamente esto multiplicó los textos
en la edad media
impulsó la alfabetización y la cultura
en esa época en esa época la gente no
leía en su mayoría pero lo más
importante que hizo es una revolución en
contra de los poderes absolutos los
poderes absolutos en esa época era la
monarquía y la iglesia ellos controlaban
con lo que estaba pasando así que no fue
un trabajo sencillo pasaron casi 300
años para que se pudiera crear la
primera plataforma herramienta de
comunicación que fue una revista esta
fue the gentleman magazine de londres
pocos años después se constituyó
cosmopolitan para los que están
familiarizados con esa revista
después de eso siguió sin ser sencillo
pasaron casi 200 años para que se
lanzara el primer anuncio en la radio
y en ese entonces no había marketing
directo y me refiero con esto que los
anuncios simplemente se mencionaba su
nombre en la radio o los programas se
titulaban con el nombre
de los anunciantes tuvo que pasar
bastantes años para que lograran
evolucionar a jim ghosn que es lo que
más conocemos en la radio
y pasaron casi 20 años donde se logra
dar otro gran paso en temas de
herramientas de marketing este es el
primer comercial de la historia en la
televisión
[Música]
lo peculiar de este comercial
seguramente no le llaman o les llama la
atención los efectos especiales
pero es que este comercial se hizo en
ese tiempo
y sólo existían 4000 televisiones en
eeuu
alguien de aquí
para que lo pongan en el contexto actual
tiene más de 4 mil followers en su
instagram habían levanta en la mano
en teoría y videos en teoría es el doble
de alcance que tuvo el primer comercial
en la historia para que se den cuenta
cómo ha evolucionado los tiempos 1954
esto sí pasó rápidamente menos de 15
años la televisión rebasa los dos medios
principales de comunicación genera más
ingresos que la radio y las revistas y
lo más interesante se le llama también
época de hombres locos
mad men hay una serie bastante buena si
son publicistas véanla
y cambio el enfoque del marketing el
enfoque antes de esto se basaba en
productos y servicios después de esto se
empezó a enfocar más en la relación
emocional y romántica con el consumidor
y es la manera en la que en la que
seguimos manejando el marketing el
marketing hoy en día te hace parte de
una comunidad que hace parte del
movimiento
telemarketing en 1970 se lanza la
primera campaña de telemarketing esta
técnica es muy efectiva aunque no lo
crean hoy en día
no sé si les ha tocado probablemente sí
que les hablan de una telefónica de un
banco etcétera bueno eso es
telemarketing en 1970 se lleva a cabo la
primera campaña a manos de sí sí hay que
es call center international compañía
que sigue vigente y siendo los más
importantes a nivel global en
telemarketing y el cliente fue ford
company la compañía de carros que
ustedes conocen 1984 bueno esto ya es el
marketing moderno aquí cambian las cosas
en su totalidad les voy a platicar un
poquito de este contexto
el mismo joven visionario steve jobs
decide lanzar un comercial de un nuevo
producto y va a revolucionar el mundo
tiempo después en medio del super bowl
jugar pieles rojas de washington contra
los raiders de los ángeles su casa era
en el corazón de silicon valley
también la casa de las empresas
tecnológicas más importante de las
últimas décadas y sorpresa
el día siguiente todo mundo estaba
hablando superbowl estuvo bueno pero
viste el comercial y esto generó tanto
ruido y tanto tanto éxito que muchas
empresas del mismo nivel empiezan a
hacerlo tradición los siguientes años y
esperan sus mejores producciones para
soltarlas en el super bowl esto es
simplemente la alfombra roja de la
publicidad
y
también son los minutos más caros al
aire
1995 un gran avance para mí en términos
de marketing digital
se lanza el ceo esto simplemente es un
buscador que nos da la primera analítica
para leer y crear estrategias digitales
se los voy a poner con un ejemplo este
fue una ventaja clara que tuvo netflix
frente a blockbuster a la hora de
empezar a construir nombre y marca cómo
fue eso crearon un algoritmo de
recomendaciones lo que te permitía que
te llegara tu correo cada día o cada dos
días recomendaciones con las películas
que tú habías visto anteriormente era
algo que no tenía blockbuster en ese
entonces y le permitió empezar a crear
un nombre por sí solo a netflix
1998 surge el concepto de blogging login
ustedes saben bien es generar contenido
a manos de estos de estos personajes que
tiempo después crean la plataforma de
twitter para el 2006 ya había más de 50
millones de blogs en la internet
2003 el año de la big data ya era tanta
la analítica que llevábamos almacenando
años con años que se crea google file
system y nos permite leer y administrar
toda esta analítica
para crear un montón de locuras y
tendencias nuevas en el marketing surge
la revolución del business intelligence
esto es la inteligencia de negocios la
mayoría de las empresas se basan en esto
surgen las analíticas y sobre todo la
inteligencia artificial yo creo
firmemente tengo la convicción que el
marketing como la humanidad vamos
caminando rápidamente la inteligencia
artificial nos va dar un ejemplo los
interlocutores que tienen en tanto en
amazon
o en apple city y alexa eso es
inteligencia artificial
pero ahorita en california están
trabajando con un algoritmo de
inteligencia donde google está buscando
la manera de que tu auto se conduzca por
sí solo y aprendan a conducir viendo
otros autos esto te puede permitir que
tu carro te deje en el trabajo y después
de eso el carro se vaya a trabajar de
uber y hacer dinero por ti y estamos muy
cerca de esos días 2004 surge facebook y
youtube bueno esto simplemente nos da
más analítica especializada es
información invaluable para las marcas
gustos preferencias horarios lugares que
visitas etcétera
a veces saben más que nosotros que
nuestra propia familia
aquí surge un concepto que se llama long
tail económico esto es economía de cola
larga
para ponerlo en un contexto muy sencillo
se los voy a explicar en la industria de
la música antes no se podía apostar ni
dar oportunidad a tantos grupos nuevos
simplemente se agarraba a los populares
porque todo tenía un costo de producción
y de distribución era muy difícil querer
generar nuevas oportunidades hoy en día
ustedes conocen
la gran lista que hay de oferta musical
pero esto no solo es para la música
inclusive hay tiendas
tal es el ejemplo de amazon que hasta
este año abrió una tienda física que
sólo existieron por años virtualmente y
tuvieron una gran oportunidad de
introducirse en el mercado esto en el
pasado era imposible 2007 no es muy
interesante este dato porque antes del
este aparato eran tres un ipad
un navegador de internet y un teléfono
no lo habíamos podido tener en una sola
y ni se diga el mundo que nos abrió en
cuanto al consumo de aplicaciones decía
steve ballmer director ejecutivo de
microsoft en ese entonces 500 dólares
por un teléfono es una locura nadie los
va a pagar
además no tiene teclado no funciona para
mandar emails bueno el resto ya es
historia
les voy a decir un dato que aplica para
todos los que estamos aquí en el
escenario 92%
de las personas que estamos aquí y
actualmente en el mundo prefiere la
recomendación de otra persona por encima
de la recomendación de una empresa o una
marca
se ha perdido la confianza en el
branding corporativo
y esto nos abre el lugar a otro nuevo
juego que se llama influencia el
marketing una herramienta muy importante
en la actualidad
que tiene bastante alcance y
credibilidad actualmente en el mercado
el mercado de influencias hoy en día
está evaluado en 4.5 billones de dólares
y se estima en el 2020 va a valer 10
billones de dólares podemos ver el
crecimiento que tiene
con bastantes pasos firmes y gigantes y
como no si la estadística es clara 60%
de las decisiones de compra en un lugar
son influenciadas por algo que vieron en
social media o en un blog
y más interesante aún por englobar todas
las generaciones que están aquí en
millenials generaciones etcétera
el promedio que pasan actualmente en las
redes sociales son 9 horas al día
queda claro porque todas las marcas
están enfocando en eso pero con esto
surgen retos y problemas tenemos la
infoxicación esto simplemente es la
saturación de información que hay en la
red
para ponerlo también con un ejemplo en
1970 una persona promedio como todos los
que estamos aquí era impactado por 500
mensajes de marca en un día
en la actualidad es el número 5000
imagínense si tuviéramos un nivel de
captación de un 1 por ciento estaríamos
captando 50 mensajes de marca en un día
por encima de todas las ocupaciones y
deberes que todos tenemos son una locura
verdad bueno esos son los retos del
infoxicación por eso bien dicen que más
es menos pero a veces mantener algo
simple es un trabajo que toma mucho
tiempo y esfuerzo más adelante van a van
a escuchar al experto en neuromarketing
en claro que seguramente
va a dejar algo muy valioso sobre estos
temas también
bueno regresando a la historia que
comencé
la mayoría de la gente asume que netflix
se come a blockbuster yo creo que esa no
es la historia completa
porque por que netflix tuvo la
oportunidad de comprar blockbuster
netflix y blockbuster tuvo la
oportunidad de comprar netflix perdón
blockbuster sabía que los tiempos
estaban cambiando creó plataformas de
streaming
pero al mismo tiempo seguía abriendo una
cantidad monstruosa de tiendas por todo
el mundo y seguía firme con su expansión
global qué quiere decir realmente nunca
como con seriedad lo rápido que estaban
cambiando los tiempos y eso pasa muy
comúnmente en esta industria otro
ejemplo muy interesante es ed sanders
director ejecutivo de motorola también
cuando salió el ipod decía un aparato
que le caben mil canciones para quien
tiene escucha mil canciones nadie
ahorita aparece en bromas pero en su
momento fueron declaraciones importantes
y controversiales
y lo que les quisiera dejar
el mensaje que yo aprendí en blockbuster
que definitivamente no lo vi mientras
empezaba a trabajar ahí pero después de
analizar todo y verlo con calma
fue claro
en la industria del marketing el status
quo es cambio esa es la única constante
el verdadero arte de esto consiste en
saber determinar la velocidad en la que
esto ocurrirá
gracias
[Aplausos]